quelques jours dans une ferme écologique
ça fera un bien fou aux élèves et à Toto
particulièrement et bien écoutez allez
mettre vos shorts et votre
anti-moustique et c'est parti hein
voici donc le corps de la ferme et elle
est où la tête
là c'est la basse
le potage il est toujours comme ça où il
est un peu
Jérôme t'es venu pour espionner ton fils
j'avais envie de prendre l'air tu es là
toi aussi je te signale
parfaitement confiance bonjour madame le
Maire levez-vous les enfants vous
appuyez madame la mer
[Musique]
deux fois plus de blagues
deux fois plus d'aventure on raconte que
dans ce château habite un terrible
fantôme
un château hanté c'est marrant
deux fois plus de Toto je suis quand
même
les blagues de Toto 2
au cinéma le 2 août